c'est le futur écrin de la viticulture
bourguignonne 3600 mètres carrés
beaucoup plus avec ses terrasses la cité
des vins et des climats de bourgogne
voit grand pour l'instant un chantier
qui débute
mais la conceptrice des lieux imagine
déjà ici très bien
le bâtiment qu'elle a créé cette grande
toiture sur laquelle on va pouvoir
monter partiellement va être plantés de
350 pieds de vigne donc c'est un micro
climats de bourgogne vous avez à cette
grande rampe en forme de vrilles
allégorie à l'abri de la vigne qui va
monter jusqu'à la toiture qui va dominer
le site et à partir de cette toiture
terrasse panoramique
on va pouvoir appréhender à
l'intégralité du paysage qu'on a autour
de nous coût 13 millions d'euros la
future cité sera géré par le bureau
interprofessionnel des vins de bourgogne
sont vingt mille visiteurs espérés
chaque année
la cité sera un véritable lieu de vie à
ce que l'on souhaite c'est effectivement
que les gens après la partie culturelle
où il vaut mieux comprendre ce que c'est
que le travail du sol que la vigne c'est
de compléter cette visite par des
ateliers culturels des dégustations
voire même des formations avec l'école
des vins de bourgogne qui sera au coeur
du projet une école qui sera aussi
présente à dijon dans la future cité de
la gastronomie et du vin
yat il risque de concurrence non selon
le maire de beaune insultes et de la
gastronomie c'était du vin a dit jean
fauque dijon se blesse c'était des vins
elle est ici tu sais tu pas la cité du
vin de cécité des vins je crois qu'une
complémentarité évidente on d2 on ne
souhaite pas du tout prendre le vocable
de gastronomie inauguration prévue fin
d'ici là les deux petites soeurs de la
cité des vins seront aménagés la
première à mâcon l'autre à chablis